the kidneys are busy organs their job is
to clean the blood and keep it
chemically balanced every day they
filter around 200 liters of it removing
waste products and making urine
the kidneys need a steady flow of blood
going in and blood and urine coming out
if this system is disrupted the kidneys
can't do their job properly and waste
products build up in the body
this can happen if blood flow to the
kidneys is interrupted during surgery if
we take a drug that interferes with the
kidneys or with blood flow or because of
illnesses like covid-19 we call it acute
kidney injury or Aki and it's quite
common one in five hospital patients
develop Aki including children although
the majority of patients are older
adults
let's take a close look at a kidney
inside there are roughly a million
filtration structures called nephrons in
Aki some of the Nephron tubes become
damaged or blocked if the cause of the
damage is dealt with quickly the kidney
can repair itself
if not the damaged nephrons die reducing
the amount of blood the kidney can
filter
the remaining nephrons grow longer to
compensate but these overgrown nephrons
are not as good as a healthy kidney full
of normal nephrons
when Aki is severe patients may need to
be put on a dialysis machine that takes
over the kidneys cleaning job giving the
kidney time to repair itself this is a
costly and complex treatment to avoid
the need for dialysis and to stop Aki
becoming a chronic condition researchers
are looking for ways to protect nephrons
and stop them dying they're testing
drugs that dampen down damaging
inflammation and others that stimulate
tissue repair or beef up normal kidney
function
to diagnose Aki doctors usually measure
the amount of a waste product called
creatinine
high creatinine levels in the blood
indicate that the kidneys are not
filtering the blood properly
low levels of urine also suggest a
problem but by this point damage to
nephrons has already occurred and in
some cases is already severe doctors
would like a way to catch Aki before
this happened
recently researchers have identified new
biomarkers of Aki proteins in the urine
of patients that are early indicators of
kidney trouble
testing for these could give doctors a
head start on combating Aki
even better would be to predict who is
at risk from Aki and try to prevent it
to do this researchers use an algorithm
to generate a risk score for patients if
you can predict who is at high risk for
example before surgery you can reduce
the risk by closely monitoring blood
pressure avoiding certain drugs and
carefully managing body fluid levels
but developing an algorithm that works
for all patients without bias is
difficult
research on Aki continues the hope is to
give doctors new tools for prevention
and early diagnosis and new drugs for
fast treatment